[Music]
the dune universe
is a universe of wonder a universe of
strange and powerful forces
and a universe of paradoxes ungraspable
by most
there are deep secrets woven into the
fabric of their reality
there are some who have the power to see
through time some who can perhaps even
move through it
there are those gifted with the power to
hear a lie
and know it or hear the truth and know
it there are many
humans that possess what seem to be
superhuman powers in dune
but can any of this be called magic
the official google definition of the
word magic is as follows
the power of apparently influencing the
course of events by use of mysterious or
supernatural forces
now there are certainly powers in dune
that are considered mysterious
though most of them are not mysterious
to those who wield those powers
but can we rightly call the powers
supernatural
here is where a better distinction
appears according to the definition of
the word
something is considered supernatural
when it is quote
attributed to some force beyond
scientific understanding or the laws of
nature
this means that in order to determine
whether or not the powers in dune are
magic
we have to figure out whether they are
understood scientifically within the
dune universe
or whether they are attributed to higher
forces beyond science
immediately when reading these
definitions this quote from the first
book appears bright in my mind
deep in the human unconscious is a
pervasive need for a logical universe
that makes sense
but the real universe is always one step
beyond logic
upon reading this quote for the first
time in frank herbert's dune book
it is easy to assume that frank herbert
is confirming the existence of magic in
his universe
but when the whole series is considered
specifically the second book dune
messiah
then that assumption is less warranted
according to the book dune
this quote is from the sayings of
muhaddib one of the books that princess
iralan wrote about paul
this means that this is something that
paul must have said in iran's presence
remember paul was trained by one of the
most gifted bini jesuit witches of all
time
the bini jesuit never did anything
without layered intent
we know from doom messiah that paul
constantly projected the mystique of his
god-like power
though he understood the complexities of
prescient power
it was impossible to relay in words
he often spoke mystically as a way to
communicate more esoteric concepts
but the mystical way of speaking never
fully reflected the truth
an example of this happens in the book
dune messiah when paul and his counsel
are discussing a treaty with the guild
you have certain powers stillgar said
can you not locate the antante despite
the guilt
powers paul thought stilgar couldn't
just say
you're prescient can't you trace a path
in the future that leads to pyle
paul looked at the golden surface of the
table always the same problem
how could he express the limits of the
inexpressible
should he speak of fragmentation the
natural destiny of all power
how could someone who'd never
experienced the spice change of
prescience conceive
an awareness containing no localized
space-time no personal
image vector nor associated sensory
captives
when stillgar presents his question to
paul paul considers the difficulty of
expressing
the nature of his abilities he knows
that there is no way for stilgart to
understand
but he knew that it would not be right
to leave him with no answer at all
stilgar though deserved an answer of
some kind
for that matter so did ireland the
uninitiated tried to conceive
oppressions as obeying a natural law
paul said he steepled his hands in front
of him
but i'd be just as correct to say it's
heaven speaking to us
that being able to read the future is a
harmonious
act of man's being in other words
prediction is a natural consequence of
the wave of the present
it wears the guise of nature you see but
such powers cannot be used from an
attitude that
pre-states aims and purposes does a chip
caught in the wave say where it's going
there is no cause and effect in the
oracle causes become occasions of
convections and confluences
places where the currents meet accepting
prescience you fill your being with
concepts repugnant to the intellect
your intellectual consciousness
therefore rejects them
in rejecting intellect becomes a part of
the process and is subjugated
paul's statement does not make sense to
stillgar paul is speaking in paradoxical
terms which apparently can only be
understood by those who have experienced
prescience
the mystical way which paul speaks
implies higher mysteries
suggesting that through prescience you
must accept one thing
and then it's opposite simultaneously
even while the logical brain rejects it
though paul's understanding of
prescience makes sense to him
it is impossible for him to relay it in
logical terms to stillgar
now of course prescience has not been
demonstrated to exist in the real world
however there are certain scientific
concepts which seem
paradoxical or logical to the
uninitiated
certain concepts can only be expressed
mathematically
and there is of course the great fact
that quantum physics which deals with
matter on a microscopic scale and
general physics which deals with matter
on a normal scale do not work together
both groups of mathematical science work
independently of each other
but they do not work together but simply
because it is not easily understood how
this could be
does not imply the supernatural i think
that is ultimately
how frank herbert saw prescience in his
dune series
earlier in this video i said that in
order to determine whether or not there
is magic in dune
we'd have to figure out whether the
mysterious abilities that some possess
were understood scientifically within
the dune universe
or whether they are attributed to higher
forces outside of science
but it's not actually that simple there
are three things we must separate here
the natural the supernatural and the
preternatural
the idea of the preternatural began to
emerge as a concept within science
during the 17th century
it was used to refer to abnormal and
strange phenomena and had the appearance
of violating nature
but was not associated with any kind of
magic or sorcery or witchcraft
the idea that preternatural phenomenon
were quote unquote
fake miracles begin to develop here
historian lorraine daston wrote a
journal titled
marvelous facts and miraculous evidence
in early modern
europe she states to simplify the
historical sequence somewhat
first pre to natural phenomena were
demonized
thereby incidentally naturalized then
the demons were deleted leaving only the
natural causes
to reiterate essentially in science the
term preternatural came to be used to
describe
basically anything science couldn't
quite figure out
something out of the norm but not magic
the term preternatural is not generally
used in modern science anymore
historically however theologians have
presented
very clear distinctions between what is
considered to be
natural supernatural or preternatural
and thomas aquinas is
on the power of god he makes the
argument
that the natural consists of what
happens most of the time
the supernatural will be the actions of
god and the preacher natural would
consist of what happened rarely
but nonetheless by the agency of created
beings
the term preternatural became associated
with demonic activity
demonic power was thought to be
comparable to use of magic by humans
also considered preternatural it was
believed that demons could indeed
perform actions beyond our knowledge
but did not have powers which
transcended
our own innate human power preternatural
phenomena was not thought to be in
opposition to divine will
but instead was thought to be hidden
occult powers that went against the
usual patterns of nature
you see the truly supernatural in this
sense
was reserved for god the preternatural
is supernatural with respect to some in
nature
so unlike the truly supernatural the
preternatural does not
elevate the creature demon or human to
the high height of the trinity
but instead adds something to the
creature that perfects its own
nature lorraine dastin also writes in
marvelous factions
and miraculous evidence in early modern
europe
although demons astral intelligences and
other spirits might manipulate natural
causes with superhuman dexterity
and thereby work marvels as mere
creatures they could never transcend
from the pre-natural to the supernatural
and work
genuine miracles the definition of these
terms has evolved and shifted over time
because general beliefs among mankind
have shifted over time
the terms also mean different things to
different people depending on their
belief systems
also these terms are attempting to make
sense of real things in the real world
that being said you can see how it's
difficult to apply these terms to
fictional universes
the existence of a god in the absolute
sense has never been confirmed or
suggested to exist within the dune
series
if we apply historical theological
definitions
anyway the abilities in doom range from
the natural to the preternatural
but the lines are blurred take the bini
jesuit power
voice for instance humans manipulate
each other through voice
every day and it is neither strange nor
mysterious
the better you know a person the more
easily it is to manipulate
them the benny jesuit power of voice as
frank herbert describes it
is merely an exaggerated form of this
the benny jesuit used their deep
understanding of human nature to control
those around them
this ability would seem pretty natural
to the uninitiated
but it is perfectly natural to the
sisterhood
the idea of prescience as presented in
dune
is much more difficult to apply these
terms to
if prescience was purely mathematical
like say
psycho-history in the foundation series
then it would fall
in the category of natural to those who
wielded and preacher-natural
in terms of those who do not since
the prescient abilities of the guild
navigators replaced the thinking
machines
which once guided interstellar travel it
would seem to follow that prescience is
based on calculation
the quizzes hatarek was someone who had
the ability to see all branches of the
possible future
and therefore become the hinge of fate
because he could see the possible
futures
he could choose which path to guide the
universe into
theoretically if the universe was in
fact predictable
then this would be an inevitable fact of
calculative prediction
such a thing would likely either require
a machine of great complexity
or perhaps a genetically engineered
human mind
again this will be an example of the
preternatural to some
but natural to the wielder of that power
now some may consider this entire thing
a matter of semantics some would say
that magic is merely a placeholder for
what we do not understand
and i fully understand this viewpoint if
magic in a fantasy series was truly
understood
it would just be science not real
science but
technically from within an internally
consistent fantasy universe
whatever force or forces that they
referred to as magic
would be just as natural and fundamental
to their universe as gravity or the
strong nuclear and weak nuclear forces
and ours
basically no one in the fantasy and
sci-fi community
agrees on most of this i asked my
followers on twitter what they thought
of this
and the largest majority agreed that
this was mostly a matter of semantics
about 32 percent said that there was no
magic in dune
and about 24 percent said yes there is
magic in dune
prominent fantasy goblin daniel green
even offered his opinion
i guess the point is it's all a matter
of perspective and relativity
it can be argued that the abilities in
dune are fictional science
and therefore there is no magic and the
opposite could also be argued
i am of the opinion that though
ultimately it's just a matter of
semantics
i do not believe that frank herbert
intended for these things in doom to be
thought of
as magic and that's what i got for you
guys today thank you so much for
watching
if you like this channel make sure you
like and subscribe and also feel free to
follow me on twitter link in the
description
and if you want to support this channel
then you can click the patreon link in
the description and pledge to me monthly
or you can also make a one-time donation
by clicking the paypal link in the
description
thank you guys so much